I think it's finally a good time to
share a few things Demar Hamlin speaks
out for the first time since suffering
Cardiac Arrest during a Buffalo Bills
game January 2nd what happened to me on
Monday Night Football I feel as a direct
example of God using me as a vessel to
share my passion and my love directly
from my heart with the entire world and
I'm able to give it back to kids and
communities all across the world to my
mom and my dad who are literally my
anchors and my everything who never left
my side the entire time to my little bro
who is my wife my reason why I strive to
be with my best self every day Demar
received an outpouring of love from his
fans and team when he attended his first
Bills game last weekend just days after
his release from Buffalo General Medical
Center
Andy showed gratitude for his fellow
players in the six minute message shared
Saturday you put Humanity above team
loyalty you showed the world Unity over
division I'm not surprised by it but I'm
deeply grateful and I'll be forever
thankful and indebted to that I mean I
think for so long we've looked at
athletes it's just physical specimens
objects of entertainment but I think our
society is starting to come around and
viewing you know being an athlete is
just a platform it's an entry point to a
larger Mission or purpose that you can
serve and I think the Mars the perfect
example of that Demar goes on to thank
his supporters with a special shout out
to the youngest members of the bills
Mafia it's always been important for me
to be a role model but just seeing the
love and the support from the youth it
just it just makes me want to you know
give back and and get out in the
communities and and touch the kids and
just be that example that they can look
to touch feel talk to and know that at
whatever they dream of it's real it can
happen if you if you stay focused stay
dedicated stay committed to whatever you
got going on welcome back to Mar
[Music]